a formar un gobierno de reconciliación
en nuestro país
esta era una de las primeras promesas de
xiomara castró tras conocer los
resultados de las elecciones que
terminaron por convertirla en la primera
mujer electa presidenta de honduras
derrotando al candidato del partido
nacional nasry asfura pero su promesa de
unidad se quebró con la división de su
propio partido libertad y refundación la
semana pasada 20 congresistas del
oficialismo rompieron filas y eligieron
junto con otras formaciones políticas a
jorge cálix como presidente del
legislativo
pasando por encima del pacto previo que
establecía que luis redondo del partido
salvador de honduras debería liderar el
congreso la sesión acabó con puños
peleas y gritos de una alianza ahora
fragmentada en dos bandos y también con
el enfado de castro
se consumó la traición la crisis
desembocó en la elección de dos
presidentes del congreso el martes
agudizando la crisis política redondo
apoyado por castro juramentó en la sede
del legislativo yo quiero agradecer a
los diputados del partido libre que
evidentemente son mucho más que los
diputados del partido salvador de
honduras por honrar por ser leales al
compromiso de su partido
mientras que cálix lo hizo por medio de
una videoconferencia en medio de un
intenso clima político y con fracturas
entre el partido que la llevó a la
presidencia xiomara castró se
posesionará este jueves y tendrá el reto
de reconstruir la unidad que prometió al
mismo tiempo en que deberá llevar las
riendas del país centroamericano